but first
time for a Christmas edition of the
fastest
first up holiday get-togethers are a
prime location for asking embarrassing
questions a new survey says one in three
people dread awkward conversations that
family gatherings like
have you put on weight
have you found a partner yet when are
you going to have a baby and why aren't
you married yet see I'm always asking
these questions Jesse by the way I'm so
glad that you came dressed in your
holiday apparel thank you so apparently
you dress for talk shows on Christmas
mornings I do yeah do you uh are you the
person who asks the awkward question no
because everybody in this group is
married has babies and is thin so I'm
not asking those types of questions but
the awkward question is the politics
because they'll bring up January 6th at
dinner oh yeah because you you're a
family that lives so that's where it
gets awkward do they really bring that
stuff I figured that stuff's been done
to death like people just know not to
talk politics well after a few drinks
it's tempting to talk politics yeah yeah
you mean after you drink exactly what
about uh you Dana has anybody ever asked
you awkward questions
uh I I suppose I suppose I'm trying to
think I I'm the person who tries to run
interference for somebody who feels like
the question was posed to them is
awkward right like oh she'll find
somebody I mean maybe you know in 2023
it'll be fine and you know I just try to
make them feel better ah well that's
nice Dana you're such a nice person see
I don't do that questions I get are
usually about you yes yeah is he okay
yeah what's wrong with Chris what's
wrong with Greg that's what people when
I go that's why I don't travel what's
wrong with you no I uh Harold you know
you probably you're like the calming
influence on every look at you you're
calm right now I'm actually whenever I
look at you I feel as though I'm
meditating
um
my conversations are a lot like Jesse's
uh there's nobody by his Merit none of
that happens and I do I don't have to
run a lot of interference I'm always
with my kid my kids are doing things sum
up with them they're young but everyone
literally asked about this show your
favorite uh your people are today I'm
very curious about about about Greg and
how they want to know about your your
show in the evening uh they love Dana uh
Dana is kind of the glue in a lot of the
people's minds that I do to show it in
Jessie because I'm the oldest Jessie's
Jesse's Jesse yeah my my buddies I tell
you but a lot of my pals particularly my
pals in college because I went to I went
to college in Philly love you and my
family members who are Eagles fans yeah
baby so what you're saying is they're
not very bright
it's like your friends who aren't very
bright that went to a so-so College
we we joke a lot but I'll tell you this
I have a lot of democratic friends and
some of my family is 50 50 dim
Republican
um and they love this show they love you
guys as you all know so it's a uh a
Merry Christmas to everybody and a Merry
Christmas your house is like America
America
what kind of questions do you ask when
you're there like where did you get out
of jail
no I don't ask that because I usually
know I put them in jail and as I've said
many times I would have put you into it
I would have let you yeah
um what kind of questions do I get asked
they know I don't want to get married so
that's the end of that and uh I guess
they ask about the show they ask about
what's going on stuff like that and
that's you know that's it I usually am
cooking I'm usually running around doing
the cooking so do the busy ones yeah I'm
the busy one I may I try to make
something that everybody likes their
favorite dishes I know that you don't
want to get married but that ring that
you're wearing right now that that is a
stunner yeah right yeah everybody you
know what I'm not getting married yeah
you don't have to wow beautiful thank
you right that's the end of that now
that I'm a dog Dad it's hard not to
spoil this little guy for Christmas
yeah there he is I was afraid they're
gonna show something else
nearly half a pay the pet parents always
get their Furry Friends something for
the holidays spending an average of 50
bucks on gifts including toys treats and
clothes judge your you've got like yeah
you got two of them right no I got three
Standard Poodles they all get gifts
first of all they get costumes but this
is for you isn't it it's not really for
the dogs no they hate getting dressed up
they absolutely despise it there they
are red ten Stella
um as Stella hates it when she gets dyed
for the holidays
um but it's believe me it's it's
innocuous it's innocent and I buy them
bones and balls and stuff that they they
the thing is you buy them toys and they
go outside they want to take their
babies with them bones with balls I used
to dance there yeah
dance there dance on whatever
uh Dana what are you you could actually
talk about what you're getting Percy
because I don't spend a dime on him I
don't I let my sister do that oh very
good oh wow yeah my sister but she's
she's got like 17 cats right three three
rescue cats after two it doesn't matter
and they are huge but so she's uh she's
very good at bringing him uh or buying
little gifts for him she's got a whole
stocking uh that was ready to go so he
he'll be said he mostly it's like any
tennis ball or some sort of ball he'll
take it mm-hmm Jesse I bet you have a
piece of advice about this well Rookie's
Jewish so he doesn't celebrate Christmas
oh did you do that
so how many days is Hanukkah eight eight
uh here we go
I don't get him anything because he
doesn't know it's Christmas of course
not so who cares yeah yeah exactly
Merry Christmas yeah Harold what about
you and your adorable pets I have three
little ones they're they're all uh
they're all rescues and they've got uh
that's Lulu the little one in the front
the little one in the back right the
stormy and the one the left there's bird
bird bird with a birdie Bird yeah
bird stays in my daughter's room she
doesn't come out very much that's the
two of them that's those are two you saw
most anyway they got they just got new
collagen new beds nothing nothing they
celebrate beds do beds that's fun it's
anti-anxiety beds that are shaped like a
big donut those things are amazing
sometimes I like it yes a little snug
for me though all right it's for my dogs
are so big my grandson goes in one and
he sits down I said to Kiki I'd love to
get him one and then he comes out that's
what happens when you'll lie down with
dogs yeah you get all right last one I
think finally just this season for
festive fibs is your aunt aunt turkey
dinner dry and hard to swallow but you
still pretend it tastes great well seven
in ten people admit that they lie to
their family if a holiday meal tastes
bad all right Harold you're kind of like
you're the politician you're smoother
than chocolate milk on a winter day I
was wondering where you were going
to wait my eyes Make the World Go Round
my mother-in-law and I make the turkey
and uh we we do we rarely drive out of
sweet potatoes so long as the sweet
potatoes are fine the sweet potato pie
is good
everything else is fine who made The
Cranberries my mother-in-law oh
unbelievable delicious I'm always
worried judge when any meal comes from
some kind of recipe from The Home
Country oh this is what for the home and
it always tastes like a peasant sock oh
I know yeah but not at a relative's
house oh I can't I can't bring it up no
it's always got a bit of relatives what
it's always safe for the relatives
because you grew up in the same kind of
food yeah but yeah they always put in
the wrong spices and oh my God where do
you go well I usually I I go to well you
know where I go to the shelter yeah I'm
alone I'm alone judge you knew that
Jesse what Greg you lie a passion sucks
no my mom really cooks well yeah and so
I don't have to lie oh that's good yeah
as long as there's one good thing to eat
at the table I'll be fine uh I will say
that we cooked the worst Christmas
dinner Thanksgiving dinner uh last year
somehow the well right now we've now we
know that our oven is broken
and overcooked the turkey at the same
time so it was like not quite cooked in
the middle and overcooked outside all
right hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else